>>> FIRST ON "TFRONT,"
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI RESPONDING
TONIGHT TO ELON MUSK AFTER MUSK
TWEETED, AND I QUOTE, MY
PRONOUNS ARE PROSECUTE FAUCI.
FAUCI SPOKE TO OUR DAVID AXELROD
IN A PODCAST THAT'S OUT ON
THURSDAY.
HERE IS A FIRST ON "OUTFRONT"
PREVIEW.
>> I DON'T RESPOND TO HIM.
I DON'T PAY ANY ATTENTION TO HIM
BECAUSE THAT'S MERELY A
DISTRACTION.
AND IF YOU GET DRAWN INTO THAT,
AND I HAVE TO BE HONEST, THAT
CESSPOOL OF INTERACTION, THERE'S
NO VALUE ADDED TO THAT, DAVID.
IT DOESN'T HELP ANYTHING.
>> IT COMES AS MUSK RECEIVED
BOOS AS WELL AS SOME CHEERS LAST
NIGHT AT A DAVE CHAPPELLE SHOW
IN SAN FRANCISCO, SHOWING WHAT A
TOTAL LIGHTNING ROD MUSK HAS
BECOME.
WATCH THIS.
>> ELON.
>> HEY, DAVE.
[ CROWD REACTS ]
>> I THINK IT'S GENEROUS TO SAY
THERE WERE SOME CHEERS.
BUT THERE WAS PRETTY
OVERWHELMING BOOING, AND IT
SEEMED TO TAKE MUSK A BIT ABACK.
OUT FRONT NOW, DAVID AXELROD,
ALSO FORMER SENIOR ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND OUR SENIOR
POLITICAL COMMENTATOR.
DAVID, WHEN YOU TALK TO
DR. FAUCI AND HE TALKS ABOUT
THAT CESSPOOL OF INTERACTION,
PRETTY REMARKABLE COMMENT
REFERRING TO TWITTER, WHAT ELSE
DID FAUCI TELL YOU IN RESPONSE
TO MUSK?
>> WELL, HE CLEARLY WAS EAGER,
AS HE SAID, NOT TO ENGAGE WITH
MUSK DIRECTLY.
BUT HE DID SAY, ERIN, AND IT WAS
REALLY INTERESTING, REFLECTING
ON HIS OVER HALF CENTURY OF WORK
THAT THIS HAS BEEN A HALF
CENTURY OF EXTRAORDINARY
PROGRESS IN SCIENCE, IN PUBLIC
HEALTH.
BUT WHEN IT CAME TO THE
POLITICAL DISCOURSE, HE SAID
THERE'S BEEN AN EROSION, AND HE
LAYS A LOT OF IT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
AND OF COURSE HE'S BEEN IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
HE WAS TARGETED ALL THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC FOR THE DECISIONS
THAT HE ADVISED AND THE ADVICE
HE WAS GIVING TO POLICYMAKERS
ABOUT HOW HE SHOULD PROCEED TO
DEAL WITH THAT PANDEMIC.
TO THE POINT WHERE HE HAD
SIGNIFICANT SECURITY THREATS
THAT REQUIRED ROUND-THE-CLOCK
SECURITY, WHICH HE SAYS IN HIS
PODCAST THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE AFTER HE LEAVES HIS
POST AT THE END OF THIS MONTH.
SO HE HAS PRETTY STRONG FEELINGS
ABOUT THE EROSION OF OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE AND THE ROLE SOCIAL
MEDIA HAS PLAYED IN IT.
>> AND MUSK DID SOMETHING ELSE,
WHICH IT SORT OF TOOK ME ABACK
ON TWITTER, EVEN AMIDST ALL OF
THIS.
HE WAS CHALLENGED, MUSK WAS, ON
TWITTER BY THE FORMER NASA
ASTRONAUT SCOTT KELLY.
MUSK HAD BROUGHT UP THE CONCEPT
OF GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH,
WHICH IS BASICALLY SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH THAT CAUSES A DISEASE
PATHOGEN TO BE MORE INFECTIOUS
AND POTENTIALLY LETHAL.
AND HE SUGGESTED THAT DR. FAUCI
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATHS
OF, QUOTE, MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
THE QUOTE IS HE LIED TO CONGRESS
AND FUNDED GAIN OF RESEARCH
FUNCTION THAT KILLED MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE.
FOR MUSK TO SUGGEST THAT FAUCI
CAUSED MILLIONS OF DEATHS, WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> HE DID ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH A LAB IN
WUHAN AND THE RESEARCH THAT WAS
FUNDED BY THE NIH THAT HE
ARGUES, I THINK PRETTY
PERSUASIVELY, ACTUALLY HELPED
DETECT WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL
STUDIES RELEASED THIS SUMMER,
INDEPENDENT STUDIES THAT
SUPPORTED FAUCI'S THEORY THAT
THIS CAME FROM A WET MARKET IN
CHINA.
BUT, LISTEN, THIS IS A GUY WHO,
THROUGH HIS WORK ON AIDS, AS
WELL AS THIS PANDEMIC AND
OTHERS, HAS ARGUABLY SAVED TENS
OF MILLIONS OF LIVES.
SO, I THINK HE IS, AS MUCH AS
ANYTHING, BEWILDERED BY THIS.
I DID PUSH HIM A LITTLE BECAUSE
HE LIKES TO USE WORDS LIKE THAT.
AND HE'S MOSTLY OUTRAGED ABOUT
THE IMPACT IT'S HAD ON HIS
FAMILY.
AND HE MADE THAT VERY, VERY
CLEAR AND THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY
AND THEIR COMFORT.
BUT HE IS VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
THE CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
DECISIONS HE MADE.
HE SAID HE'S READY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE CONGRESS.
THE REPUBLICANS SAID THEY'RE
GOING TO CALL HIM BEFORE
CONGRESS.
HE SAID THAT GETS THE BROOKLYN
UP IN HIM, A